being led up in the office who ran
flapper water to corporate most of our
ownership and leverage taking protectors
that out those average
[Music]
what advice would you give to someone
who doesn't know what to do with their
life try as many things as possible and
get into the yes business instead of the
no business what advice would you give
someone basically starting over 28 years
of age don't realize how lucky they are
in the daily life they should start over
or how lucky they are they were forced
to start over at an age or they're still
[ __ ] baby
what is the mantra for quoting you
goodbye you're going to die
the media landscape is changing so much
the whole you know it's super
interesting because I've been in this
for so long this is a big one
very what's your ultimate vision for
yourself your company for myself my
funeral will be attended by far more
people than anybody realized that's for
me for my company that I build one of
the great entrepreneurial media business
empires of all time and for the world
that it continues to do what it's doing
which is at a macro it always always
always is better than it was the day
before even if the headline is trick you
into not believing that
[Music]
this isn't about social this is about
the Internet these are websites on top
of the Internet
that's what those six apps are the
Internet is what's killing television or
the the structure of the traditional
television set you guys know there's a
fourteen-year-old girl let her clean the
five most famous people to her they are
not two thirty eight year olds and 54
year old spec YouTube use 100% 100%
understand I realized that the coast
later personal relationship millions
people just by posting one two things
that speaks directly folks because of
that grip and they really lifted me up
in that show came out for all intensive
purposes you would not have known I was
on that show based on the market again
it came out and they pushed the great
possible before the show started you had
like thirty I was looking out there
reaching for their not urging for the
weekly the who's doing what they were
going social media like a console
shuttle what you doing every single day
and then I feel that there they are
looking for personality so I people if
they can connect you in that
and always by the way but they had no
option in the past
Thank You Man oh let me give you let me
give me working yeah yeah I want to give
you the one that if you're going to
leave it it's gonna actually bring you
value can get me mascara me yeah you
demanding you live every run nice create
so many sentences you can give you
friends only or friends I've got it you
guys
unfortunately this can never happen I
was born in the Soviet Union dunk just
can't happen breasts we weren't born in
this great country I can't become
president know if you're not born in
America you can't become president even
if you're an American city
correct I'm American citizen since birth
oh you're an American city looking
you're right you can be right right oh
[ __ ]
get out of here you understand
psychology yes I understand what you
understand so I this can I get a
normally what happens with fashion of
material is it Instagram is a very
democratic platform and people make a
business by trying to kind of keep
fashionable civil and exclusive so I
actually opened up like I was the first
Indian designer to kind of take measures
on Instagram so I came the format of our
children it's been a super successful
for
makes me happy man it's a tension
arbitrage right it's it's it's wherever
the attention is the game when there's a
coup they go after the media the media
dictates the mentality and that's what
this I agree man I mean this is where
you know what the best part is if you're
an optimist which I could tell you are
in four seconds if you're not the miss
is the greatest thing that has ever
happened in the world very exciting the
Internet is an incredible thing
Instagram for your industry at this
moment at this time is
disproportionately powerful my friend
such a pleasure but it's really nice
meeting every key what were the
presentations we had so far
energy the culture company by the way
for anybody here who's on who plans to
build a very big business there'll be no
more important meeting than that one the
only thing that allows you to build a
business of any true scale scale meaning
50 a hundred million dollars like for
real it's all people DT seek you know
you know container by container it's all
the stuff you know but like the right
way is your right way with knowing that
as much as you can care about zero
economics for as long as possible you
will win the only right way for a
business to have a heartbeat is for to
not be driven by the wallet you know why
you're doing it unless I'm a good
listener for all my interrupting and
interviews you said I have to stay in it
for the legitimacy and you're 100% right
so you know why you're doing it so stop
complaining about to yourself you are
doing one thing it's the engine got it
got it is wrong yeah you're you're you
look you doing one thing I'm doing one
thing involved thing Gary Vee and being
Gary Vaynerchuk is one thing it seems
like it's not
got it you're doing one thing got it
yeah that's the game you are doing the
right thing you can go fast now you're
gonna go faster when I tell you the name
has zero now the name a drive you
you know like fun when you name
something up there child there may be
that bad day two in the morning
something bad up folks spoiled shipment
your [ __ ] you look at me like no no uh
right like sometimes the name can do
something like that bore yet but it's
not the [ __ ] name it's not the idea
the execution for DS isn't going to work
because I randomly thought over the idea
during a meeting and I went on Facebook
a lot and Instagram live it's because
we're executing yes
[Music]
my funeral 100 [ __ ] thousand percent I
am so pissed that I don't get to see my
grandchildren sleek the [ __ ] out of how
many people show up to this thing
I love journey I don't even want to find
a jack I just want to try to I'm video
that's super weird it's like eight years
old and it's like it's gonna be the
worst day of my life I'm going to play
it maybe this crazy day that all of you
gonna freak your [ __ ]
America's gonna freak I'm gonna make
only the world care about me buying the
jet and then when it's going to happen
everybody's going to go [ __ ] crazy
and whatever TV or Facebook or video
consumption platform of the time in 20
years is I'm going to play a video and
if I say world this is the worst day of
my life that's the most macro my love of
the chase of the climb of the truth the
ultimate is my death I'll never be able
to get there I won't be able to see it
and that's why it's the most romantic
thing for me so anyway that's my North
Star I'm giving you a really big piece
of advice I know I'm right it's a space
I've spent a lot of time looking at
because it has a lot of similarities to
my tech world if you are the person that
can capture the energy of what I said
you can't imagine how life-changing that
can be for you the problem is you have
to have enough talent to pull it off
today an Asian artists let's do it
ha are you really the questions uh
better I do as a pleasure Gary yes the
three biggest trends you see in digital
archiving today audio enormous Lee
passionate about audio believe that
podcasting and Alexa skills and the
Google home platform I believe that
audio is going to save humans time which
is why it's super valuable and is not
only my number one but my number two and
three trend and I'm obsessed with what
kind of charity to gain a following to
get them to get known as your hip-hop
musician
the poor frog you need to get your music
heard so the best way is to actually
make good hip-hop music because if your
product sucks you're finished but if we
assume that you're good I would reach
out and DM on Instagram every person
that creates content and offer your
music for free to them to be playing in
the background so that you can cite them
their audiences awareness to hear your
music and for them they're getting the
music asset that may make their videos
better you have to bring people value
the most one is the collective home
screen of every 15 year old in America
because I want to know what one or two
things they're doing that I don't
understand yet that then I can manifest
into theses that will bring me
opportunity suck we should do this again
this is good yeah this is liking it
yeah this is yeah yeah yeah we need this
matter we should this is really I mean
this podcast podcast piece this is
something good right
send me up on Twitter right now and just
say it's good how [ __ ] awesome was
that let me know actually it's a good
time I'm going to throw a right hook
because I think I just delivered [ __ ]
the greatest job of all time if you have
not reviewed my podcast yet it would
mean the world to me if you end my way
if you think my podcast is a piece of
[ __ ] go give me one star but if you've
not reviewed it yet one way or the other
this would mean a lot to me if you would
go and do that right now thanks for
listening
cleaned up yeah I'm going straight hi
what do you think I'm going to the
[ __ ] moon [ __ ]
[Music]